las mi brazo atravesó caracas para
bendecir los restos de su esposo
fallecido por kobe 19 en la única misa
que realiza la iglesia católica en el
país en automóviles pudo conseguir uno
de los 30 cupos disponibles para este
servicio que sólo se celebra cada 15
días cuando el xxiv y lización de
cuarentena nosotros somos bastante
católicos y queríamos antiwar las
cenizas de mi esposo que ya bueno ya hoy
cumplía 8 días ya de no haber días de
fallecidos por bueno porque teníamos
muchísima febrero y no para pedir por su
alma la parroquia santuario de la
coromoto decidió copiando iniciativas de
otros países traer los feligreses al
templo con distanciamiento social las
normas de asistencia son similares a las
de los autocines no más de cuatro
personas por vehículo es obligatorio el
uso de mascarilla y nadie puede bajar
sin interactuar en estos días difíciles
de encierro donde muchas personas
católicas requieren de apoyo espiritual
te extrañan ir a las iglesias
iniciativas como esta le dan fuerza y fe
para sobrellevar las dificultades tengo
seis meses de la pandemia que no he
podido venir a la iglesia yo soy
católica practicante y me pareció
excelente y me dejó un alimento
espiritual que nos conforta nos da
fortaleza en estos momentos tan duros
que estamos viviendo no solo de la
pandemia sino la de situación país la
conferencia episcopal venezolana ya
tiene los protocolos de higiene
necesarios para que los feligreses
retornen a los templos de manera normal
por ahora la decisión está en manos del
gobierno nacional de definir una fecha
para que puedan realizarse nuevamente
reuniones en lugares cerrados
herminia fernández france24 caracas